art
and magnus with the white pieces will
make the first move
and uh time control in blitz david
remind us the time control each player
will have five minutes on the clock for
the whole game but they will gain three
seconds after every move and magnus
opens with one b3 hippo
this could transpose to the hippo of
course this opening was made famous last
year by adiban who brought out a very
very good chessable course
and uh yeah he wants to keep the tension
no commitment in the center no opening
theory uh yeah what do you guys think of
this simon i can tell you love it
already you're excited yeah i mean i
always like seeing a different opening
uh you've got your main line openings
and you've got your more sideline
openings and we we see this very rarely
and i like seeing rare openings it's
more fun you get you get very
interesting middle games
this has not been mapped out very deeply
as compared to the other openings
and now here magnus has got to decide
what setup to go for though this is kind
of a you know the next stage what what
setup does he want does he develop his
knight does he go back to a more
mainline idea by moving his queen's pawn
does he even go for a dutch does he go
for a hippo play the hippo magnus oh
come on you can play the hippo i mean
spending too long though he hasn't
adjusted yeah what will be the move with
uh it's the hippo wow
not this one okay wow white would have
just played a pawn move on the third
rank
if you wanted the hip opening instead he
gives up the bishop i would never
consider doing that in a million years i
mean uh
that you know just giving up the bishop
we love our bishops giving out that
bishop with great range
yes you double blacks pawns but you know
that's that's a big decision massive
decision huge and uh okay so prior
unsurprisingly there had only been four
games in my database without move and
i'm just shocked magnus is breaking the
rules here but this is the hippo about
the bishop he's actually gone for the
hippo
bishop there he needs two bishops for a
hippo beautiful
i mean white would love his dark bishop
back right now uh on the plus side black
does have a dilemma duda which side is
he going to castle on
if black's king goes this way to the
right side castle and king side there is
a bit of a hole due to a set of doubled
pawns if you go the long way it's just
going to be chaos both sides will throw
pawns pieces at each other's king
it's very tempting to go the long way
though castle on the opposite side to
white
is is magnus gonna start to try to hunt
this light square bishop that's uh
outside of the pawn chain and yep
here he comes
so i'm pretty i'm presuming that he's
not just about uh capturing that bishop
but instead maybe he might want to
advance some pawns and
just call some questions yeah lock it in
uh push that f pawn forward perhaps
and uh dude look he's hovering if you
look at dude's screen he's hovering over
black's doubled f pawns he wants to push
one of them forward uh is he gonna do
that now okay magnus occupies space in
the center very logical uh now that
magnus has parted with his dark square
bishop he has to put pawns on dart
squares to kind of exert some control
there
on the okay duda is he really about to
push his h-bomb forward that looks a bit
weird looks a bit loose yeah and it's on
the board yeah does he want to initiate
a kingside attack later
he's really asking magnus to trade off
that white knight on the edge of the
board for that he's got the neiman
bishop there isn't he you know that that
light squared bishop if you've been
following the coverage the other days we
saw that hans niemann has been left with
this bishop and there you go the neiman
bishop is on the board yeah um but look
this was the whole thing you know that
knight is not obliged to move
we've got the bishop in its purest form
yeah purest form i mean that's an impure
bishop with its uh
range blocked that black light square
bishop
just locked out the game for the near
future yeah possibly even the long
future i love this move he's planning to
bring that knight back around right you
know with that last move
and it is that that yeah the light
squared bishop big pawn we call it
he's killed one of his opponent's pieces
uh at least he's dominating one of his
opponent's pieces so magnus will maybe
try at some point soon to switch the
battle over to the other flank while
black is kind of messing around with his
king with his pieces on that side
i mean it's just incredible like the
strategic
kind of mastery that he has
just the understanding of move free
giving up the bishop of the night and
then you get this like 10 moves later
how does he do it you know it's like
amazing you know amazing new ideas which
i love seeing you know i think it's like
some magic spell that he kind of casts
on costs on his opponents because
it doesn't make any sense the way that
uh
dude has played you know it just feels
like he's on full-on tilt mode he
doesn't want to be there he should you
know he's thinking to himself i should
have won this match
i think dude is still dwelling on the
past yeah totally i mean it still seems
that doesn't seem that bad at all for
black saying that i mean uh yeah you've
got the bad bishop but your knights in
the center you might have a chance to
push a pawn on the king's side i don't
know how but
it's not terrible by any means just a
little bit worse black yeah it's a bit
like the last uh the last game with duda
he's
solid not that many weaknesses but he
just doesn't have a plan right yeah or
at least not one that we can see over
the next two or three moves maybe dude
has like a longer uh kind of
sophisticated sequence where he can
somehow extricate his light squared
bishop in front of his king and onto a
better diagonal but
we don't see it yet it's just all about
again like like the last game it's all
about whether magnus can improve
uh it's not so easy for magnus actually
there's just so many pawns it's so
locked up
it's just maneuvering magnus does have
one idea in his pocket and obviously
it's not great now but it's just simply
to capture the pawn in the middle
because black is obliged to capture back
with the sea pawn and suddenly there is
an open line but it's not good now
because white is not ready for the
opening
so
it's just something to always bear in
mind that and something that dudeo must
calculate on every move yeah white's
queen i really want to i was going to
say i really want to slide her across
one square white's rook in the left-hand
corner
that one needs to activate and uh it was
due it was previously just kind of uh
protecting a pawn now at least white can
double up some rooks maybe go oh dude
that is a weird that's an impatient move
um maybe it's a good one maybe it's
completely fine but it just looks like
it's so weakening and there we go the
evaluation bar does react
in this pawn structure i would never
ever touch that pawn i would just say
okay i'm gonna shuffle
come at me but he's just saying okay i'm
coming to you and uh when duda has such
a bad bishop like he does on the light
squares
uh yeah that's not gonna really work
there's a lot of holes in black's half
of the board white has
everything covered in his half what do
you guys think yeah no i'm i'm liking my
magnus's position more and more
um
yeah i think the white knight is going
to come to the f4 square the bishop is
actually
you know doesn't have a role on h3 it's
going to come and re-route itself to f1
and suddenly just look at every single
one of white's pieces they have a
purpose they have a function
and
black
yeah i mean his position is still
holdable i mean it's still okay
but you know he does have an uphill task
ahead of him
and uh with the clock ticking down i'm
really really worried for duda yeah 20
seconds or 30 seconds now below on the
clock i mean just look at the squad
yeah sorry david i was just just saying
look at the light square bishop it's
embarrassingly bad isn't it it really is
and uh putting a rook behind it he's
just
his bishop's in the way now i know and
we'd love to just pick his bishop and
just throw it off the block
swap it for anything like a pawn i don't
know like you know it's i mean
i don't know how that's ever going to
get back in the game and these long term
things they they matter greatly when you
when you play magnus and the white
knights i mean it's closed position
you've got two nights nights work well
in closed position this is the move that
david i think you know you pointed out
that pawn lunge that black played
allowed that rook to go to that square
black was covering that square with a
pawn before the only plan i can see for
black is to oh
i thought that he would just trade
everything off and just
yeah maybe just try to give create some
kind of attack on the
right but this looks
i mean i mean there will be no attack if
you have a bishop like that one bad
piece uh also white's knights protect
his king okay he's trying to open up
lines he's swapping off his isolated
pawn that's good but magnus just pushes
forward
um yeah interesting i was gonna say the
white knights will protect their king
the black king looks pretty safe as well
so i'm not sure who this favors but
i guess it's gonna favor the side with
the most active pieces i guess magnus is
just trying to play on both sides at the
moment isn't he but
yeah i'm a bit surprised that magnus
pushed that g pawn as well i i don't
know if he needed to do that but it is a
blitz game they're both now under two
minutes
so it's going to really heat up now you
get a bit of time added on each move at
the moment how are your nerves magnus
and young christoph
the white knight entering the center of
the board
um yeah if white gets a couple of moves
he would love to shuffle his king into
the corner and then that white rook will
swing the whole way across line up
against the black king if black gets a
couple of moves i guess you want to
prioritize kicking away white's knights
or that white rook that's kind of sat in
the black camp but
it's not easy to do either of those to
be honest yeah you don't really want to
trade off black's dark square bishop for
one of the white knights because black's
dark square bishop plugs all those holes
in his camp
uh the white queen is a bit misplaced
maybe she needs to join the battle at
some point but
is it urgent what can black do in the
meantime
and yeah nice tweet there about the
neiman bishop i'm not sure what's worse
neiman's bishop in this game against uh
prague or this black light square bishop
here which is
just in the way
yeah i mean it it's it's just such a
terrible piece i mean
you've got to be very careful just
shutting your own bishop in i mean it's
been a bit of a theme today the light
square bishop actually in this match
you know both even magnus had a very bad
you know very bad bishop earlier on uh
when when duda was cruising and i like
this move because you're kicking the
knight away now your queen can uh swing
over to to put some pressure on black's
king as well
and
i really think
you know the the black king could could
soon be under some nasty fire here big
pressure coming is there any
any idea that black has of generating
some play by kicking some pieces back so
okay the pawn attacks the night the
night
has to go back i don't see a way of
moving it forward yeah that white knight
probably just retreats
but yeah i love white's last king move
the white rook is ready to swing the one
in the corner the whole way across
white's queen and rook
are going to kind of switch sides which
it's rare to see pieces able to kind of
be so mobile
um what is magnus
worrying about here i guess if the white
knight retreats maybe black will
continue advancing some pawns at some
point but
there's nothing wrong with a retreat
here wouldn't it be funny if neiman's
bishop becomes the winning piece yeah
somehow jumps out from his passive
square and gets the white king and
checkmate i mean this is the first time
it's breathed any fresh air since uh
yeah
in the last 10 15 moves
you can see it potentially having
is some to go for the kill now i'm not
sure this was needed sacrificing a piece
right yeah he's gone for a peace
sacrifice which piece is sacrificed he
sacrifices in the middle and uh just a
pawn and
yeah maybe but dude says okay i don't
trust you i'm calling your bluff that's
the right thing dude needed to suffer
for something at least he's a piece up
now as black
all of white's pieces are good but
where's the killer blow black's king has
a lot of defensive pieces around it
i guess you can
capture a pawn in the center but
yeah it's so complicated now
and both sides around 30 seconds
this one
objectively it doesn't matter it's just
about who can
uh who can react quickest okay he does
take a pawn there's a pin on the g file
with white's rook so
white isn't giving up a second piece
the white queen is quite handily placed
on the diagonal to the black king as
well
but it is a piece right i mean this is
really risky now now any result possible
here because
if magnus doesn't check mate he's going
to lose on material um so he needs to
now go for the checkmate
okay the black king's stepping back
there's all sorts of pins i mean there's
a pin on the sixth rank with black's
rook in the corner looking all the way
across to white's rook uh in his camp
i mean black's king is so open the white
queen yet to join the battle
it's difficult to kind of calculate so
bush takes bishop he's a whole rook down
like this
wow temporarily a whole rook down he
might win some of the material back but
i mean this one oh wow what a move he's
going in on the light squares this is a
kind of switchback oh i say what a move
but the white queen's been look at the
bar
yeah i got that queer first
a little race
dramatic guys the white queen needs to
get in on the light squares otherwise
magnus is just a rook down
she's not getting in black's queen is
covering everything it's incredible
black is a whole rook up
magnus under 10 seconds as well dude is
up the pace he's up the gears
[Laughter]
switches back
black's just trading rooks though
i said my gosh it's so hard to call this
game anything could happen look at the
barkai
one
the king is safe as houses looks safe
is it i mean i guess the black queen
though yeah
the players in the pictures if they
react the king just cannot survive black
is winning right
off the rooks and white's bishop drops
to the black queen oh wow after a check
first magnus looks away he's just
blundered his house oh no everything's
fallen white is a whole rook down in an
end game
brilliant we're going to reach the
endgame checkmate's going to come well
done duder brilliant brilliant sort of
he took his opportunity magnus played
very very riskily there and uh dude dude
managed to defend
uh that's it checkmate in a couple of
moves there we go it's a result duda
takes the win wow what a comeback by
duda magnus winning the two last rapid
games it looked great for him in this
first
blitz game with the white pieces but
duda
wow he takes the win and the lead in the
blitz tie breaks in five minutes game
number two will start magnus with the
black pieces he has to win it to take it
to armageddon a draw or win